speaker and thank you General Assembly I
have the distinct honor today to welcome
a dear friend and a dear man amongst our
community I would like to introduce and
welcome Mr Daryl Ridgely to the floor
Carroll County resident for 35 years his
wife maklesha is in the audience today
they have two adult sons Andy and Luke
pastor at mclemoreville Baptist Church
and the state real estate broker
Auctioneer cattle farmer Carroll County
Commissioner for seven years so for our
ways and means people this is our budget
guy of Carroll County if you need help
call Daryl he will help you out
exceptional at that aspect
um graduate of Waverly Central High
School
Bethel University graduate and just a
phenomenal man my personal relationship
with this guy when I was running I
didn't know what a treasure was and they
told me I had to have one and they told
me you find somebody with a bigger name
than you that means more to your
community than anybody can think of so I
put Daryl originally on the spot and
made him become a Treasurer so I'm
standing before you today because of
this man's name and the character that
he is I heard numerous times on a
campaign trail that if Daryl originally
has your name on it it's going to work
out just fine so I greatly appreciate
what he's done if I could sum him up in
three words it's Christian humble
servant so Mr Daryl if you don't mind
reading this in prayer thank you
hear these words from Psalm 33 blessed
is the nation whose God is the Lord the
people he has chosen as his own
inheritance let us pray
oh lord god Jehovah the one who dwells
between the cherubim and the seraphim
You Are God Alone of all the kingdoms
and nations of the Earth and universe
you alone by your Mighty power created
the heavens and the Earth including this
piece of paradise that we all call home
we thank you for the blessings of life
you have given to each of us we bless
your holy name and give thanks to You O
Lord for allowing us to live in this
great state of Tennessee
I praise you and thank you Lord for
those who have assembled to serve to
lead and to legislate on behalf of the
great citizens of our precious Homeland
Tennessee
may your holy spirit guide each one who
votes today and may the foundation of
your holy word the Bible be the
principles upon which they lead and
serve today and always
I asked your continued protection upon
all within the sound of my voice today
and upon their families we pray this day
Lord God that you will fill our hearts
and Minds to love others just as your
only son Jesus Christ chose to love each
of us we thank you for Jesus and his
sacrificial death upon a cross for the
many sins we have committed
Empower this legislative body O Lord to
do your will today and always
for only in your will is Everlasting
peace and contentment to be found
grant them wisdom
discernment and courage in all matters
that come before them we pray we ask all
these things in the strong and powerful
name of Jesus Christ your son
amen and amen
represent Martin will lead us in the
Pledge of Allegiance
tension salute fled
pledge allegiance
of the United States of America
to The Republic
ANS
Mr Clark please take your role roll call
Mr Clark please take the role Mr Speaker
95 members president
let the journals reflect Representatives
love Carr and Dixie are excused
next order Mr Clark welcoming and
honoring we have presentations so hang
on hang on
representative Slater you're recognize
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker I
request that the sergeant-at-arms escort
Our Guest into the chamber Mr sergeant
of arms please escort the guests to the
well
[Applause]
representative Slater you're recognized
Mr Speaker the Sumner County delegation
is pleased to Welcome to the house floor
today members of the concert choir of
Liberty Creek High School Liberty Creek
High School is one of the newest high
schools in the great state of Tennessee
in fact this is the inaugural year for
Liberty Creek a beautiful campus right
in the heart of Sumner County and we're
certainly thankful to have them here
today there are many items of note for
Liberty Creek High School but one of the
things that I would point out to you is
that there are only two other places in
the United States where there is a
flight simulator
that is of the caliber that is at
Liberty Creek High School
one of the places is Embry Riddle
and the other is the United States Air
Force
and so among many notable things uh
we're thankful to have right in Sumner
County a great High School these
students they're led by their director
uh Miss Pam Andrews who over 20 years
has served in Sumner County Schools
we're thankful today to have their
principal in the back uh Dr Philip Holt
who is of course the inaugural principal
of the high school we're thankful to
have them here today and they're going
to present for us two numbers
thank you
oh stay can you see by the dawn's early
what's so proud
ly now at the twilight's lastly
trying Bright Stars
we watched were so
gallantly stream
[Music]
dreams
that our flag was still there foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
we also I was just going to say so much
of your dedication that you give to us
we appreciate but I wanted to especially
dedicate this song to all of our
veterans that are in the audience we
have many here so we want to dedicate
this to you and and this is Aaron he's
going to sing for you
tell him
[Music]
if tomorrow all the things were gone I'd
worked for all my life
and I had to start again with just my
children and my wife
thank my lucky stars to be living here
today cause the flag still stands for
freedom and they can't sink that away
[Music]
and I won't forget the men who died who
gave that right to me and I gladly stand
up next to you and defend her still
today
cause there ain't no doubt I love this
light
I bless the USA
from the lakes of Minnesota
to the hills of Tennessee
across the plains of Texas
from sea to shining sea from Detroit
down to Houston and New York to L.A
there's pride in every American Heart
and it's time we stand and stand
that I'm proud to be an American where
at least I know I'm free
and I won't forget the men who died who
gave that right to me and I gladly stand
up next to you and Defender still today
cause there ain't no doubt I love this
land
God Bless the
USA the USA
and I'm proud to be an American where at
least I know I'm free and I won't forget
the men who died who gave that right to
me and I gladly stand up
next to you and Defender still today
cause there ain't no doubt I love this
land God Bless the USA
God bless
there ain't no doubt I love this side
God Bless the USA
that you use
[Applause]
[Music]
representative slider Mr Speaker could
you join us in the welfare photo please
represent grills you're recognized
thank you Mr Speaker it wasn't that
awesome
uh Mr Speaker I request that the
Mr Speaker I request is the sergeant of
arms escort our guests into the chambers
Mr sergeant of arms please escort the
guests to the well
representative grills you're recognized
thank you Mr Speaker these eight
individuals are the state officers of
the FFA and I'd like to introduce them
uh first if you would Faith cook would
you raise your hand so everybody know
who you are
um she is the state Secretary from
Wilson County East Tennessee I mean East
Tennessee State vice president Jay
Caldwell from Washington County
Middle Tennessee State vice president
Hannah May Dale
now Hannah you and I were on a team
earlier this year or last year at the
state fair and we did not do so well
because I believe representative boy
cheated right
that's correct
a West Tennessee State vice president
Jared Tubbs
State Treasurer Garen Hambly
State reporter Anna Collins
State Sentinel Scarlett cook
and our state president is uh from my
County she's my uh she lives about three
miles from me Miss Taylor Cantrell I
just want to tell you that Taylor has
been one of those ladies that the
underclassmen in her school Whenever
there was someone a freshman or someone
who needed a mentor she was always that
person who would show up middle of the
night to deal with a sick goat pig or
whatever and she just has an excellent
reputation amongst the folks there in
our County and if you would Mr Speaker
I'd like Miss Cantrell to introduce
herself and maybe make a few remarks
absolutely recognize it thank you for
that beautiful introduction he only
knows those things because he pulled up
to the middle of our high school Barn
probably at midnight as I was trying to
pull a kid and a calf across the road so
we have had amazing time bonding but
this week is National FFA weekend my
team is so excited to be here and just
to get to know you all and get to know
what goes on right here we would like to
tell you that across the the way we have
an FFA room where we have members set up
where you can learn a little bit about
our organization again thank you for all
that you do for agriculture and for
Tennessee FFA it's an honor to be here
with you
[Applause]
represent girls Mr Speaker if you would
join us in the well and any other member
that has a constituent up here that I
can take a picture come on up
foreign
all right we're under welcome and
honoring and just a note for all members
we do have a wall of pages today so if
you need any help please
show The Freshman which button to push
all right representative Wright you're
recognized
thank you Mr Speaker it's an extreme
honor and pleasure that I rise on the
floor of the house today to recognize
recognize the 16-year legend
of the House of Representatives
please make welcome Harry Brooks
representative Williams
thank you Mr Speaker
the FFA group that was just in here
Congressman Rose uh was with them today
I wanted to wish him today is his
birthday 29 again he says but uh Happy
Birthday to congressman John Rose uh and
his lovely wife Chelsea welcome them
back to the hill thank you
represent carringer
thank you Mr Speaker first I'd like to
recognize a former County Commissioner
out of Knox County that served with some
of us here from Knoxville Hugh Nystrom
and his son Trace he is here working on
his Eagle Scout award so I wanted to
welcome them but then I also have a bit
of sad news I know all of y'all remember
representative Bill Dunn he lost his one
of his brothers unexpectedly this past
Monday
Paul Dunn III and they will be receiving
friends tomorrow night in Knoxville and
the services on Saturday
so I just wanted to take a moment to
remember this family
um I've been there and I know how
difficult it is and Only God in prayers
get us through these moments so we're
just like take a moment of silence
remember the Dutton family
thank you thank you representative
Halsey
thank you Mr Speaker I would like you to
make welcome my godson Bill Toler
sitting back here and a friend of mine a
Mark Carrier and Mark's son Marcus
they're here visiting from up my way
representative Martin of Carroll
thank you Mr Speaker I love all my
constituents but I have my most two
important constituents on the floor
today my six-year-old son Steele is a
pager behind the wall and then you guys
always ask why I'm able to do this with
a practice at home I have the speaker of
my house here today with me as well
Krista Martin on the floor with me
thank you Mr Speaker
[Applause]
representative land
thank you Mr Speaker representative Boyd
and representative Hale and I would like
to welcome uh the Mount Juliet FFA
chapter Chad Lewis the ACT teacher and
all the students I understand they're on
the right side there they are please
help me welcome them thank you
representative Martin of Hamilton
thank you Mr Speaker
um we have lost a great man in our
community
Jimbo a Slingers the fire chief he's
been the retired fire chief of the cell
creek volunteer fire department today
they will lay his remains to rest and I
wanted to honor him and ask for just a
moment of silence
thank you
representative Darby
thank you Mr Speaker we've got the three
pages up here behind you they're from
Bruceton uh Hollow Rock brewstone
Central High School Mr Seth Thomas
Thatcher Cruz and Parker Finley and I
appreciate Trey Crews the CTE director
at Bruceton for bringing them we've also
in the sea of blue here and I don't know
exactly which side they're on but we've
got the world renowned Martin Westview
FFA with advisor David hawkrider and CTE
director Carl Rogers and we also have
the Henry County FFA with Mr chance
young
thank you Mr speaker thank you
representative kiesling
thank you Mr Speaker I'm absolutely
thrilled to have three of our FFA
chapters here with us today to my left
to your left members and I'm going to
ask the Macon County and red ball and
springs remember to chapter members to
please stand these are our future
District 38 leaders thank you all and to
your right we have the Mark Twain
chapter out of Alvin C York up in
Fentress County would you please
make these Future Leaders welcome thank
you
representative Moody
thank you Mr Speaker and members I'm
pleased to welcome in the chambers today
some of our directors of our Pregnancy
Resource Centers from across the state
and also legislators you are invited
immediately after session to go to the
old supreme court room downstairs below
us and they will be down there and come
see your director please come join us
thank you thank you
representative Eldridge
thank you Mr Speaker I'd like to ask the
members if they would help chairman
Faison and I welcome the Hamblin County
chapter of FFA and their instructors up
there miss Overby is one that they're in
just make them feel welcome
representative hell
I want to ask the members if they would
to help me welcome we've got four of our
FFA chapters here today from the 40th
District Cannon County Smith County
DeKalb County and Gordonsville and also
uh my son playing hooky from school even
though he's not in FFA Maddox is here
with us today
representative haston
thank you Mr Speaker please help me
welcome the Perry County High School FFA
up here to my left y'all stand up thank
you all for being here
leader Lamberth representative Garrett
and representative Slater
thank you Mr Speaker I'm here with the
Williams of Sumner County representative
William Lambert representative William
Slater I am honored today to welcome all
of those folks FFA chapters from Sumner
County from Beach High School Liberty
Creek High School Station Camp High
School Portland high school and White
House High School if you are here and
your name was called please stand up so
this floor can honor the Future Leaders
of this state
then did I forget Hendersonville
which was the top of my list
thank you all for being here
representative White
thank you Mr Speaker as we continue to
recognize individual chapters I just
wanted to stand up and honor all the
young people here this morning of FFA
I want you to know just how much we
appreciate Who You Are
and the quality of life that you're
leading in we're really going to look
forward to your future leaderships thank
you stay the course thank you very much
for being here
thank you
representative Freeman
thank you Mr Speaker I might be a touch
out of order I know things are going to
get heated in here today but that
doesn't mean that the room also needs to
be hot could we get the air turned down
a little bit
once we flip the switch that means
you're in for the cold the rest the
session
supposed to get cold this weekend we'll
work on it
we'll work on it represent Butler
thank you Mr Speaker I wanted to
recognize my wife is up in the gallery
over here we celebrated our anniversary
yesterday and she's always been uh my
biggest Advocate and supporter
[Applause]
representative Fritz
thank you Mr Speaker I would like to
recognize the Panthers from Lenoir City
High School FFA let's give them a warm
welcome
[Applause]
representative mcalmon
thank you Mr Speaker I would like to
have the members in this room welcome my
mother Reba as well as a dear friend of
ours Mary Lynn up in the gallery this
morning thank you so much
[Applause]
speak bro Tim Marsh
thank you Mr Speaker I'd also like to
welcome the Cascade FFA chapter and
their advisor Mike Swafford and the
Shelbyville high school and Community
High School from Bedford County welcome
thank you
representative Kumar
thank you Mr Speaker welcome to all the
FFA delegations and members we admire
what you do
I want to especially welcome those from
Springfield High School in Robertson
County thank you for being here
thank you
representative Sparks
thank you chairman
thank you members members we had a
terrible situation happen to a Smyrna
high school student y'all probably seen
the news channel 5 had done a great job
of covering this situation young lady 16
years old Janae Edmondson standout
volleyball player she was in St Louis
for a tournament and tragically struck
by a car sadly she's
looks like she's gonna lose both
both of her legs and
you know I'm reminded my sister Vicki
who was a volleyball player at Smyrna
high school and a softball player had a
college scholarship sadly she's confined
to a wheelchair
but I want to ask the members to really
pay attention to this situation because
it's become political in St Louis the
mayor of St Louis is calling out the
local
Circuit Court attorney to resign mayor
teresia Jones
it's very interesting this young man it
was 21 years old
was
let out charged with um
under house arrest
he had 50 GPS violations
and really shouldn't have been out
and the case hadn't been heard so
there's a big Fallout on this
I couldn't imagine what she's going
through but
thanks to the media I think there's
three hundred thousand dollars that's
been raised on a GoFundMe project for
but I want to call on
one of our local athletes chairman Scott
sapicki to just do a prayer for for
Janae and her family representative
members if you'll pray with us forward
this young lady dear heavenly father
Lord we pray
for courage for this young lady as she
faces great challenges in her life as
she moves ahead
we pray for her family
that they have comfort
we pray that she will lead the life that
she is expected to lead Lord that you've
given to her to its fullest
Lord we pray that she'll be an
inspiration to others as she takes this
tragedy and steals victory
in the end
Lord we pray a blessing on her and her
family and all those involved that they
will see your way Lord and your mercy in
Jesus name we pray amen
representative Stevens at representative
Spark's desk
thank you Mr Speaker I just wanted to
recognize all of the FFA groups in
Rutherford County I'm not sure if
they're in the gallery because some of
them had a meeting in the hallway with a
senator but I wanted to welcome them and
thank them for coming to be with us
today
thank you
all right anyone else under welcome and
honoring representative cappley
thank you Mr Speaker and members myself
and chairman Doggett would like to honor
someone that we lost in our community
this past week
um the retired former police chief of
Linville Police Department he was also a
police officer in one of my home
communities in Lawrenceburg he was lost
last week and he leaves behind many
friends and family members and he was a
true public servant to his community so
if we could all please take a moment to
silence
thank you Mr speaker thank you
representative Cheryl
thank you Mr Baker up in my left up in
the gallery we do want to welcome a
group of folks from White County if you
would raise your hand up there welcome
them would you please thank you
[Applause]
is there a rule on the house floor about
how many times you can recognize a
freshman during welcome and honoring
twice all right representative Martin
O'Carroll you recognize
thank you Mr Speaker I would be amiss if
I didn't recognize my Clarksburg FFA up
here in the top
they're here today thank you for all
they're doing
thank you
all right anyone else
welcome and honoring
Miss clerk next order please
introduction to resolutions
mayor Lambert you're recognized thing Mr
Speaker that all resolutions properly
filed be introduced Pursuit for number
17 and play something insane Capital
refer to the thermostat committee
objection so order next order Miss Clark
Senate joint resolutions congratulatory
memorializer Lambert you're recognized
thank you Mr Speaker with it all Senate
joint resolutions congratulatory
memorializing line with an Espy play
something insane caliber silver number
17. with objections or next order Mr
Clark resolutions lying over Lambert you
recognize hey Mr Speaker that all
resolution slide overview appropriate
static committee an objection so order
next extraordinary Clark introduction to
bill Senate bill is on first
consideration well there Lambert you're
recognized thank you Mr Speaker for the
Senate bill is 12 259 263 transmitted by
the Senate be held on the death between
third consideration of the companion
house bills with objection so ordered
next door to Mr Clark Senate Bill's on
second consideration house bills on
second consideration letter Lambert you
recognized thank you Mr Speaker with the
house bills
1542-1548 be passed on second
consideration to be held on the desk
refer to the perfect standing committee
objection so order next order Miss Clark
petitions and memorials
Miss Clerk Mr Speaker we have a brief
statement dated February 13 2023
addressed to The Honorable Tammy letzler
Chief Clerk of the Tennessee House of
Representatives it reads dear Madam
clerk please accept the attached
application by address from Arthur J
Hirsch of Lawrence County Tennessee Mr
Hirsch seeks immediate dissolution of
the unconstitutional Board of judicial
conduct by this legislature on the
ground it clearly violates Tennessee
Constitution Article 6 section 7 judges
holding prohibited office respect signed
respectfully clay Doggett state
representative for district 70 chairman
of Criminal Justice subcommittee Mr
Speaker this uh application by address
is available for review by any member
who wishes to do so thank you Mr clerk
chairman Zachary you're recognized
thank you Mr Speaker I moved passage the
consent counter or third and final
consideration in keeping with rule 50.
hang on Jeremy Zachary Mr Clark
Mr Speaker the next order is reports
from standing committees report some
select committee's calendars Mr Speaker
the house as a consent count there we go
all right chairman zacher you are now
recognized
thank you again Mr Speaker I've been
pasted the consent calendar on third and
final consideration keeping with rule
50. gentlemen moves passage of extinct
counter probably second Mr Clark came in
Jackson's been filed Mr Speaker item 28
Senate joint resolution 159 has been
objected to by chairman Faison
anyone seeking recognition on the
consent calendar
seeing none we're voting on the extent
counter our members favor vote out when
the bell rings those vote no as every
member voted zoom in which change the
vote Hardaway eye Campbell I
camper eye
Dixie eye
Williams eye
missed Clark please take the vote
eyes 94 known as two president I voted I
received Constitution's majority I
declared sink underpass objection the
most Greek sitters table
next order Miss Clark Mr Speaker the
house is a regular calendar clock first
bill Mr clerk House Bill 29 by chairman
sapicki relative to developmental
instruction in higher education chairman
speaky you're recognized thank you Mr
Speaker I move passage of House Bill 29
on third and final consideration
chairman speaking moves pastors probably
second to Mr clerk Club First Amendment
please education instruction committee
amendment number one Charlie lady Moody
you're recognized
thank you Mr Speaker this amendment
allows a State University to coordinate
with a two-year institution to provide
remedial coursework even if the
university already offers said
coursework a move to adopt Journey moves
adoption Member One probably secondary
discussion on the amendment see none all
this favor amendment number one say aye
aye or those posts say no the eyes
haven't you adopt the next man Miss
Clark Mr Speaker no further amendments
chairman speaker you're recognized thank
you Mr Speaker members this bill
authorizes a public institution of
higher education to offer remedial or
developmental courses or coursework to
address student remedial needs Mr
Speaker I renew my motion
chairman speak he renews his motion any
discussion on the bill
seen none any objection to the question
see none all those favor House Bill 29's
amended vote I when the bell rings I
suppose vote no as every member voted
zoom in West change your vote
Mitch Clark please take the vote
Ah that's 95 no days House Bill 29
having received conscious majority clerk
Pastor objection the most Riggs Thursday
well Bob next bill Mr Clark
House Bill 486 by chairman chairman Boyd
relative to campaign Finance chairman
Boyd you're recognized thank you Mr
Speaker I moved past it's a house bill
486 on third and final consideration
chairman boy moose passages by me second
and Mr clerky an amendment's been filed
Mr Speaker no amendments filed chairman
Boyd you're recognized thank you Mr
Speaker members House Bill 486 uh
although it involves political action
committees it's a relatively simple bill
under current law political action
committees have to report to the
registry at the state level and the
reporting uh criteria and the the
frequency of which they report matches
what we do as candidates for as state
representatives and so I discovered a
little-known statute that a lot of
people are unaware of last year and that
is that if a political action committee
makes a donation to any local candidate
it creates a reporting requirement to
that County and so since we now have
such a such a robust system at the state
level and anyone on planet Earth with
access to the World Wide Web I can look
up and learn anything about the
political action committee this would
actually eliminate the need to report to
local election commissions and would
consolidate all the reporting under the
state
Mr Speaker I renew my notes
chairman Voyager news his motion any
discussion on the bill
seen any objection to the question
see none
all those in favor House Bill 486 vote
Iowa when the bell rings I was supposed
to vote no as every member voted as any
member was changed the vote Lambert eye
camper eye
Crawford I
Mr clerk please take the vote
I was 96 no names I was Bill 46 having
received constitutional majority out
here by cleric Pastor objection the most
recent series table
Now by chairman Todd and others relative
to adult oriented performances Mr
Speaker Senate bill is on the desk
chairman Todd you're recognized
thank you Mr Speaker I moved to
substitute and conform to Senate Bill
three chairman Todd moves so student
performance Senate Bill 3 probably
second without objection so ordered
Todd thank you Mr Speaker I moved
passage of Senate Bill 3 on third and
final consideration chairman Todd moose
passage of send Bill three on third and
final two raced by protective Mr clerk
caught First Amendment house criminal
justice committee amendment number one
chairman Halsey you're recognized thank
you Mr Speaker this amendment rewrites
the bill and I move adoption a house
criminal justice committee amendment
number one and defer to the sponsor for
further explanation chairman Olsen moves
Houseman number one property seconded
any discussion on the amendment
all those in favor adoption house bill
number one say I I'll those folks say no
the eyes haven't you adopted next minute
Miss Clark Mr Speaker no further
amendments
chairman Holzer you recognized
oh I'm sorry chairman Todd you recognize
thank you Mr Speaker
as was stated Amendment one makes the
bill as amended Senate Bill 3 clears up
confusion in the law and clarifies that
adult oriented performances may only be
held in age-restricted perform locations
and may never be held on publicly owned
property under current law businesses
that predominantly provide adult
oriented entertainment must be licensed
and age restricted to prevent children
from entrance
this bill simply clarifies that if this
type of adult oriented entertainment
occurs in locations that are not
required to be regulated under the
current law because the adult
entertainment is not predominant to that
business like a restaurant for example
then that business must ensure that the
location is age restricted and children
are not allowed to view the performance
the bill only applies to performances
that are considered harmful to minors
under the state's obscenity laws which
are those performances that are overtly
sexual in nature and that appeal to a
prurient interest this is a well
understood term in Tennessee obscenity
case law surrounding what it means to
appeal to a perian interest
this is a common sense child safety bill
and I would appreciate your support
thank you Mr Speaker
do you renew your motion
renew my motion thank you chairman Tyler
news's motion any discussion on the bill
representative Johnson of Knox
thank you Mr Speaker
so we already have obscenity laws on the
books if you are being in scene of in
front of children it is already illegal
correct
German time
that is correct
representative Johnson
thank you
um so
if you're wearing Lederhosen and being
in obscene in front of children you will
be arrested correct German time
the bill has several things laid out
that require
that are required before you would be
arrested or be charged with a crime
representative Johnson but aren't those
things already illegal if you are being
obscene in front of children
chairman Todd this bill clarifies that
entertainment
adult entertainment within an adult
oriented establishment regardless
whether a fee is charged or accepted for
entertainment regardless of whether the
entertainment is provided by an employee
and also provides that a performance of
adult or simulated specified sexual
activities including removal of articles
of clothing or appearing unclothed are
illegal
representative Johnson
I'm thinking of a whole lot of
performances where people remove
articles of clothing that doesn't make
it a um a stripping situation but you
can remove a jacket you can remove is
that including this as well chairman
Todd
things that are not sexualized would not
be included in this
representative Johnson
can you define for me female
impersonator
Germantown
Mr Speaker that is something that she
would have to refer to the law that we
already have on the books for I do not
have that definition memorized
representative Johnson
is there a definition in the law for a
female impersonator
Mr Speaker
as amended Senate Bill 3 clears up
confusion in the law and clarifies that
adult-oriented performances may only be
held in age-restricted venues and may
never be held on publicly owned property
under the current law
business businesses that predominantly
provide adult oriented entertainment
must be licensed and age restricted to
prevent children from entrance
this bill simply clarifies that this
type of adult-oriented entertainment
occurs in locations that are not
required to be regulated under the
current adult entertainment law because
that entertainment is not predominant to
the business such as a restaurant or
some other venue
then that business must ensure that the
location is age restricted
that minors must not be present
and the children not be allowed to view
the performance the bill only applies to
performances that are considered to be
harmful to minors under the state's
obscenity laws which are those
performances that are overtly sexual in
nature and appeal to a prairie and
interests
39-17 901 defines harmful to minors that
quality of any description or
representation in whatever form
of nudity sexual excitement sexual
conduct excess violence settlements
abuse
when the matter or performance a would
be found by the average person applying
contemporary Community standards to
appeal predominantly to the prurient
shameful or morbid interest of mine
representative Johnson you're out of
order you can allow him to finish but we
will not take shouting from the house
floor thank you very much chairman Todd
you can continue thank you Mr Speaker B
is patently offensive to prevailing
standards in the adult community as a
whole with respect to what is suitable
for minors and C taken as a whole lack
serious literary artistic political or
scientific value for minors
there are other definitions as well that
deal with adult oriented establishments
but I hope that answers the question Mr
Speaker representative Johnson
oh thank you it doesn't answer the
question actually because what we're
doing is this is going to have a
chilling effect on things that aren't
obscene performances because I haven't
seen obscene drag performances but that
is the Target and the the thing that we
are targeting here and so the reality is
we are violating people's first
amendments rights we're having a
chilling effect on how different people
um do performances we have drag queen
being
very well representative Harris you're
recognized
thank you Mr Speaker so for clarity two
things has to happen in order for
someone to violate
um this legislation that would be one a
minor would have to be present and two
it would have to meet the definition of
harmful to a minor
um absent of those two parts
would that be the understanding of this
legislation chairman
thank you Mr Speaker
this address is adult Cabaret
entertainment
and that means in the bill it says adult
Cabaret entertainment means
adult-oriented performances that are
harmful to minors as I just read the
definition of
as that term is defined in 901 and that
features topless dancers go-go dancers
exotic dancers strippers male or female
impersonators or similar entertainers
and this is required include a single
performance or multiple performances by
an Entertainer
Entertainer then is defined in the bill
as meaning a person who provides
entertainment within an adult oriented
establishment
regardless of whether a fee is charged
I'll skip over to the next section a
performance of actual or simulated
specified sexual activities as I just
read
are included in that Entertainer
definition
representative Harris
for clerk for clarification an adult
entertainment adult Cabaret
entertainment by definition here is an
adult oriented performance many of our
communities host annual family-oriented
lgbtq Pride events each year so this
would not apply to those since those are
family oriented correct
German Todd thank you Mr Speaker it's
not my place to determine what is going
to apply here or not the language is
extremely clear much more clear than I
believe what we have in code at the
moment and Mr Speaker I just believe
this will make it much easier for the
public to determine what is exactly
appropriate for children and what is not
appropriate for children and what can be
performed in their presence or without
their presence
representative Harris
who will be responsible for enforcing
this law chairman Todd
thank you Mr Speaker
responsible parties for enforcing laws
in this state has not changed by this
bill
representative Harris
who will be responsible for enforcing
this law chairman Todd thank you Mr
Speaker
the same folks that enforce the laws
currently will be enforcing this law
representative Harris have there been
any instances where this has been where
an adult Cabaret in public has been
harmful to youth
chairman time thank you Mr Speaker
this past year in my community we had a
local group decide to do a quote family
friendly Pride or a family-friendly drag
show
and when they it listed this as family
friendly my community rose up we filed
an injunction against this group
actually against the city of Jackson
because our city mayor was endorsing
this and refusing to use local
ordinances to prevent it that were very
clearly set there to prevent this type
of activity in front of children
the end of that after spending several
thousand dollars of individual donations
we had folks come from all over the
community donating to this effort to
stop this from from being in in front of
our children
it was forced to be indoors and 18 and
up only and I was asked to
come up with legislation that would make
this much more clear
it came down to a definition I found a
definition of the word Cabaret that is
not in current law
and when as I understand from talking to
our legal team when you don't have
something to find in law and you go to
the dictionary so we went to the
dictionary and the word Cabaret can mean
either a performance or it can mean a
location
so we've certainly felt like in my
community felt like it was both it could
be both but we took that to court and
got the injunction and got it moved to
indoors and away from kids and that's
that's exactly what the way this bill is
structured doesn't prevent those
performances it certainly says that they
must not be held in front of minors and
we intend to uphold that and expect our
law enforcement across our great state
to uphold that principle and uphold what
we pass here in this legislature
representative Harris
thank you Mr Speaker
representative Hardaway
thank you speaker
and good morning to the sponsor
I'll tell you one thing I learned is not
to ask a question until after I finished
making my statements
the
um
the issue that hits me and I can't see
the sponsor I wish I could so he could
see me
there we go
uh the the issues that hits me is in uh
section one
and it's because we
we have language in there that
is specifically calling out male or
female impersonators
that's a problem for me
I was sitting and making a couple of
notes of mail or female impersonators
who have been on TV
regular for decades for male or female
impersonators who
are in the movies the theaters
who are in the uh the plays that often
come to public venues
and I came up with Martin Lawrence I
can't remember what the name is of the
uh the individual
that's a first that's that's now in the
records
uh Tyler Perry Big Mama
number of movies family oriented but at
times there are
suggestive scenes or comments or
movements uh in that movie uh Red
Skelton and I was a little boy when I
was watching Red Skelton for those who
were trying to date me
uh Flip Wilson Geraldine
from my understanding of the amended
Bill the amendment uh house bill number
nine all of those would be forbidden and
they would be committing I think you
moved it to it uh
uh Taipei misdemeanor all of them would
would be breaking the law once this bill
passes
um
and I just don't understand why we had
to
to put language in that spoke to male or
female impersonators
it just doesn't make sense to me
I've gotten in most of what I want to
say so I'd be interested in hearing your
responsor
German time thank you Mr Speaker I would
clarify for the members that the wording
in that paragraph is copied out word for
word of the current law that we have on
the books we haven't created any new
language in that paragraph
Maybe by adding an s or something
similar entertainers maybe but the rest
of that is copied straight out of the
law as a matter of fact this amendment
that we have that makes the bill there
was a in the Senate version there was
one phrase there that was left out of
what the current law has and so we added
that back in and to make it again
consistent with what's been on the books
for literally decades that was passed
long before this majority was in place
so that that's been there that's what we
dealt with this past summer in my
community that's what folks went to when
they looked up what can be done about
this this type of performance in front
of our children and saw that and said
wait a minute how can we have such a
thing in this community in a public park
when it clearly says male and female
impersonators cannot be in those
locations and so that's what started the
whole discussion around the law and
around this particular advertised
performance and what we could do about
it
representative Hardaway thank you and
I think he just told me that male or
female impersonators uh is in current
law
not asking a question right now I'm
gonna wait until I get to the end of my
time before I ask another question
but
I myself uh actually had a bill
that I took over from Kerry Todd as a
matter of fact that dealt with adult
cabarets I don't remember seeing that
language and I still would say it to you
to uh to hold out the uh the male or
female impersonators
in this listing of topless dancers and
exotic dancers and strippers I say that
that unfairly uh puts them in the
chairman Todd
thank you Mr Speaker I renew my motion
thank you representative Freeman
thank you Mr Speaker I'm going to follow
along some of the lines my my colleague
um it it troubles me that we are
including
um male and female impersonators in the
same light as a as a as a stripper
um and you know there are several
organizations and and restaurants here
in Nashville that do
um you know Sunday Drag Brunch that is
not sexual in nature uh that is
normalizing the transgender uh community
that is showing those that come from
your community and and from all across
our state that that they have a place in
our state
and by somehow trying to not somehow by
by trying to outlaw their existence we
are further uh traumatizing tennesseans
and I I guess my question to you and I
would ask for brevity I don't know if
I'm gonna get it but my question to you
is
um what is wrong with a transgender
person that we need to create a law that
makes it so they cannot
be in public in front of children why
is it a problem for a child
to simply be in the presence
of of a transgender person and I would
also challenge the fact that that
someone is impersonating uh a male or a
female if if they are
um if they are transgender and or in
Drag
because I don't believe that they are
impersonating I believe that they they
feel like that is who they are and why
do we need to tell them
who they can be
chairman Todd
Mr Speaker
the language in this is very clear and
it is literally copied out of the the
definitions that we already have so this
hang up with male and female
impersonators we've had on the books for
decades previous legislatures passed
that this is just copied out of that and
using that definition to expand on it
and clarify again from based on my
experience and our community and what we
dealt with with that definition
so we wanted to make sure that it was
very clear going forward what would be
and would not be caught in this and as I
stated earlier
this this actual the other entertainers
that are mentioned here and then the
word similar entertainers defined as
entertainment within an adult oriented
establishment and then we get into
what's harmful to minors we've added
that as Clarity to this so that we don't
catch folks that are just expressing
their first amendment rights walking
down the street or something so this
this is not going in the direction I
don't I don't believe where you were
thinking it is I think it actually is
making it more clear to everyone to be
able to understand this represent
Freeman
thank you and and I I appreciate the
answer but again I'm going to ask you a
direct question so if somebody is having
an all-age uh Drag Brunch and there is
no nudity
under this law is is that required to be
an 18 and up establishment if it's
because I you keep saying an adult
oriented establishment and I'm not sure
I'm not sure I understand that term
German time thank you Mr Speaker
so as it lays out it lays out what an
adult Cabaret entertainment is in in the
first paragraph a
then in the next section Entertainer it
defines that and it's entertainment
within an adult oriented establishment
and also means a performance of actual
or simulated specified sexual activities
involving removing of articles of
clothing or appearing unclothed
regardless of whether a fee is charged
or not
and it's harmful to minors I mean this
this fits into again what we've already
had into our law in our law for decades
and just clarify so that it's very clear
to performers and average citizens as to
what is allowed representative Freeman
thank you thank you for that so I'm
going to take that as a yes then that if
you were just having a A Drag Brunch uh
at at a restaurant here in Nashville
that that would be allowed I I just want
to
say one quick thing in six seconds
we're missing this we need to be
accepting of all tennesseans and I hope
that every
let the German flag leader campers
excuse
you're recognized
thank you Mr Speaker
I was going to rise today and talk about
how this bill is a solution in search of
a problem but I believe that my
colleagues on the other side of the
aisle already know that
this is about erasing a group of people
it's about fear-mongering it's about
waging a culture War it's about
manufacturing a crisis to distract from
the failures of this majority to do the
will of everyday tennesseans
and many of you know that
because the truth be told if we wanted
to address the issue of obscenity and
what is harmful to minors my colleagues
on the other side of the aisle would not
need a bill in the House of
Representatives
what they would need is a mirror
it is this majority that until last year
defended a member from Waynesboro who
admitted to being a child molester when
he was a coach it was my members on the
other side of the aisle my colleagues
who defended a speaker the former
speaker
despite his continuous acts of looting
and appropriate behavior including with
interns it was my colleagues on the
other side of the aisle who defended a
president who talked about grabbing
women inappropriately with no shame
and so if we want to look
represent Jones if you'd like to stay on
the bill that would be great if you go
off the bill then we will have this
little debate back and forth so please
stay on the bill thank you
representative Jones
thank you Mr Speaker this bill is about
obscenity and things that are harmful to
children
that is what I'm staying on Mr Speaker
if we want to look at what is seriously
harmful to Children let's have a bill to
ban children from going to these Bible
camps where they're being sexually
assaulted with the Southern Baptist
convention let's go after real threats
to our youth let's go up to the
predatory behavior in your own districts
clergy in your own congregations harming
youth
weekly we read about this in the news my
my colleagues I'm saying this
to just say let's be serious about what
this is about
let's be serious about what's at stake
here I want to quote a drag queen an
lgbtq activist and an icon from The
Stonewall Uprising Marcia P Johnson who
stated how many years does it take for
people to see that we're all brothers
and sisters and human beings in the
human race
you may not agree with going to drag
shows you don't you're no one's forcing
you to go
but don't try any raising a whole
identity of people because of hatred and
bigotry in your heart
we are constitutionally sworn and taken
oath to vote against any legislation
that is injurious to the people attacks
on freedom of expression are injurious
to the people violating constitutional
rights injurious to the people
scapegoating and instigating violence
against a group of people injurious to
the people
and so I urge my colleagues I know your
leadership has told you to vote on this
bill but vote according to what you know
is right vote according to what your
District knows is not an issue this is
not no I've gotten multiple calls about
this bill from East Nashville to Antioch
across my district hundreds of calls not
one person supported this bill until
this was filed no one even knew this was
an issue until the sponsor made it one
and so colleagues I ask you to just do
something right be on the right side of
History
let's be about the issues that are
serious to Everyday tennesseans who are
suffering for denied Health Care poverty
wages poor public education systems
let's not make issues just to win cheap
political points let's not manufacture
crisis just so that we can give
ourselves a platform to distract
tennesseans from the failures of this
majority Miss
Repton Jones you're off the bill we're
moving to the next one representing
Clemens you're recognized
foreign
speaker uh thank you sponsor appreciate
my previous colleagues sentiments about
this and and the targeting you know
often though we disagree with
legislation we try to find the true
intent and
perhaps the love and a piece of
legislation but I don't see any Love in
This legislation I see hate and so in
addition to that
my concern with this is the breadth of
the language Mr sponsor and the breadth
of this language takes direct aim at the
local economy of my city
it takes direct aim at the entertainers
within my city it takes direct aim with
its small businesses in my community
and so the language of this bill
now I don't know if you've ever attended
a Beyonce concert something tells me you
have a
or a Harry Styles concert or a lizzo
concert or a Madonna concert your
language
prohibiting
and the breadth the vagueness in this
bill
would prohibit those entertainers for
performing in my city
it would prohibit Beyonce that queen bee
herself who is coming to Nashville this
year
this bill would allow me as a district
attorney by the Plain language of this
bill to arrest Beyonce
is that your intended goal here
Germantown
thank you Mr Speaker
it is so interesting to me to hear the
opposition to this very simple
Common Sense Bill most of you in this
room know exactly what this does you
know it's Common Sense anyone that would
stand against a bill
that is going to prevent miners children
from seeing obscene sexual activity
I don't know how you claim to be
representing anyone
this is common sense this is protecting
children first and foremost
we can folks have made up things about
this they've dreamed up things about
this we've got you know media weighing
in on it from all over the world without
reading it without really looking at
what it means it does exactly what I
said it does
it's very plain and simple and I would
think an attorney of all people would be
able to read this and certainly
understand how simple it is thank you Mr
Speaker represent Cummins
out of order
president Clemens
thank you Mr Speaker you know it's
interesting we can find Common Ground
here nobody wants a a minor in an
establishment With a Stripper there are
laws prohibiting that
but your language here as a lawyer
that features any entertainment that
features a topless dancer you could have
male topless dancers
I mean I guess we're not going to
swimming pools anymore if males aren't
allowed to take their shirts off so you
got male topless dancers performing in a
public venue
and that may or may not have actual or
simulated sexual activities removed or
including the removal of articles of
clothing such as a t-shirt
I mean you you could have a child I
don't know if you've been to ascend
Amphitheater you can watch performances
from the street without entering that
venue so you could have a 16 year old
walking up the street looking in a
concert at Beyonce Harry Styles lives up
any any most any Entertainer
and then you're going to allow a
District's attorney to go down there and
arrest that Entertainer you are taking
direct aim at Music City USA just
because you subjectively may not agree
with it
now we talk a lot of in this body about
protecting Constitutional Amendments
so if you want to have the plain
language of the Second Amendment
protected then you better want to have
the plain language of the First
Amendment protected
because you can have constitutionally
recognized exceptions but you cannot
exclude individual classes of people
because you subjectively disagree with
them or hate them
that is unconstitutional your language
is vague
and it's overly Broad
this will not stand up in court you have
wasted all of our time here today
by promoting this legislation
I would ask that you at least make the
effort as an attorney
to clean this up to bring it within
constitutional muster so you're not
attacking my local economy thank you Mr
Speaker
chairman Todd you're recognized
thank you Mr Speaker I think the
language is extremely clear we've had
multiple attorneys look over this they
think it's extremely solid I'm very
confident very confident our attorney
general can stand behind this and defend
this without question
representative Zachary
thank you Mr Speaker members I had not
planned on speaking on this bill but
after hearing all the comments I thought
it was appropriate to provide some
actual context so in Knox County we had
a drag show a family-friendly drag show
that was set to be at the Tennessee
theater there's a Christmas drag show
video surfaced of this showed that
showed stripping simulating of sexual
acts and inappropriate touching and so
because of that the mayor and I engaged
the facility there were some compromises
made but then some videos surfaced that
showed exactly what went on on this drag
show and I'm extremely thankful for TBI
director Roush who's the former Chief of
Police in Knox County for engaging and
actually bringing the Promoter on the
promoter agreeing with the director's
assessment and then agreeing to scale
down that show to make it appropriate
for children which is exactly why this
bill is needed to ensure that those acts
don't don't continue in front of
children because that same show two days
or three days after Christmas was
conducted in Florida without that same
filter and those restrictions and now
the save in Florida is invest
investigating those because there was
simulation of sexual acts stripping in
exposure and inappropriate touching and
let's be really clear really clear we as
the legislature we have the ability per
our constitution to deem what is
inappropriate and my guess is when we
vote and put this on the board and when
we vote on another bill that we put on
the board these were all conversations
that happened during the election cycle
and I need to remind this body and
remind my colleagues we picked up two
additional seats in the house and the
governor who was a republican Governor
increased his percentage so we talked
many times about a mandate from the
voters we have a mandate from the voters
they agree with us in protecting
children and that's exactly what this
bill does so I remind my colleagues when
we vote here and we vote now and we're
voting on this bill it is about
protecting children thank you Mr speaker
thank you representative Todd for your
boldness in carrying this bill
out of order
representative bolso
thank you Mr Speaker
I've heard three
statements made this morning that I wish
to comment on
the first
is this statement on the bill
the second has to do with the
Constitution
and the third has to do with hate
first
it's the obligation of every member of
this body to read and understand the
bills that come before it
when we look at section 1A of Senate
Bill 3 we see that adult Cabaret
entertainment is defined to mean adult
oriented performances that are harmful
to minors as that term is defined in
39-17-901
that provision has been ignored by every
question lodged this morning
if you actually look at
39-17-901 subsection 6. it provides a
definition
as to what is harmful to minors and it
provides for three things one the
conduct has to be puriant it has to
appeal to puriant sexual interests
number two it has to be patently
offensive and then third it can have no
redeeming scientific or artistic value
now we didn't just make those terms up
that's the three-part Miller test coming
from our U.S Supreme Court in 1973 in
Miller versus California and when you
look at Senate Bill 3 it defines adult
Cabaret entertainment to include conduct
that is harmful to minors and it doesn't
say or it says and
the conduct has to be obscene as defined
by the U.S Supreme Court in Miller
versus California and it has to involve
topless dancers go-go dancers and other
things so this idea that somehow just
appearing in public as a male or if
you're a female or Flip Wilson
impersonating Geraldine has nothing to
do with this bill because to be unlawful
the conduct first has to be obscene as
defined by the U.S Supreme Court and
through
39-17-901 codified in Tennessee and then
second it has to involve topless dancing
go-go dancers or other such things
that's Point number one on the bill look
at the bill read the bill
Point number two the Constitution that
you just heard about this bill is
completely constitutional
it it is it reeks with constitutionality
under the First Amendment because it
incorporates the test that our Supreme
Court adopted in 1973.
the third point is hate let me say this
about hate
in this attitude of intolerance that is
taking over our country this
dictatorship of relativism
this bill is not born in hate this bill
is born out of love to protect the
innocence of children and I am proud to
stand with representative Todd to
support it out of order
representative Warner
thank you Mr Speaker I have a previous
question please bring previous questions
been called any objection
we'll go on the board that's fine
we're voting on previous question all
those in favor vote I when the bell
rings all those opposed vote no
as every member voted does any member
wish to change their vote
Mr Clark please take the vote
hi 74-29 is previous question prevails
let the journal reflect representative
Beck is accused
we are voting all those in favor of
Senate Bill 3 as amended vote Iowa when
the bell rings those opposed vote no as
every member voted does he remember
which change their vote
Mr Clark please take the vote
I have 74 19 days Senate Bill 3 haven't
received Constitution's majority I hear
about declare a passive objection most
Greek series table
next bill Mr Clark
House Bill won the leader Lambert and
others relative to medical care of the
youngness because the Senate bill is on
the desk Larry Lambert you're recognized
oh
chairman Clement is you're recognized
thank you Mr Speaker I the issue and I
certainly understand and members are
entitled to call the previous question
on the floor under the rules but I do
think
Mr Clerk and correct me if I'm wrong do
we not have a mechanism under the rules
that we are allowed to have someone
recognized to correct a misstatement
made by someone else on the house floor
if it is a blatant intentional
misrepresentation of the actual facts
Mr Clark
Mitch Clark
Mr I believe what the member may be
referring to is if a member's reputation
has been called into question they would
have a right or if their name is called
they would have a right to respond as
far as to clear up any sort of record
that's not the case
Jeremy Clemens
thank you Mr Speaker and I appreciate
you entertaining the question on this
parliamentary issue I do find it
unfortunate that we are unable if
someone makes a blatant
misrepresentation or misstatement of
fact
um that we do not have a mechanism
whereby that can be corrected for the
public record I I certainly would hate
for this body to be tainted with blatant
misstatements in debate on an issue as
important as the last bill
um and I'm not I'm not speaking with
regard to different interpretations of
the Constitution or anything like I'm
simple facts about where something took
place and where it did not take place
those things matter for the record and
so um I'd just like for us to consider
that in the future if we're able Mr
Speaker
foreign
we would we would have been on this bill
for two hours on the other side
misstating according to what other
people had said so it goes both ways but
our policy is if you raise your hand you
go on the list if you like to clear up
someone's information you have that
right to go on the list
if someone calls your name as a clerk
says then you're able to respond
immediately
or if they impugn someone's reputation
you have the right to immediately
respond outside of that we are in the
process that we're in
leader Lambert you're recognized
thank you Mr Speaker move to substitute
conform to Senate bill number one
literally substitute Forum Senate bill
one probably segment with objection cell
order later Lambert thank you Mr Speaker
with the move passage of Senate bill
number one on third and final
consideration learn language passages
send Bill one on third final second Mr
clerk caught First Amendment house
health committee amendment number one
chairman Terry you're recognized thank
you thank you Mr Speaker I moved to roll
to the hill of the amendment it's an
objection roll to the hill next minute
Ms Clark how Civil Justice committee
amendment number one filed as house
Amendment two chairman farmer you
recognized thank you Mr Speaker I'd make
a motion move to the hill the objection
roll to the hill next minute
house Amendment Three by chairman Hulsey
Mr Speaker it was timely filed chairman
holds it you're recognized
thank you Mr Speaker
um I want to tell you how I
got in this mess
two weeks ago I got a call from a man
that I know and respect in my district
concerned about a couple of things in
this bill not in the bill I'm sorry a
couple of things in the findings
one of them was the verbiage
about three days later I got an email
from a respected constitutional lawyer
that I know in the county next to mine
and he said you've got to fix this or
pull your name off the bill
then others begin to contact me and then
some Heavy Hitters contacted me and
that's how I ended up here
I want you to understand that my
amendment is very short it doesn't do
anything to the bill
IT addresses two things in the findings
here's the first thing there is a
statement in the findings that says the
state of Tennessee has a compelling and
legitimate interest
in Dignity of children
I am told that that is a very dangerous
statement to use
in today's argument and the reason for
it is is for two reasons one
in the Supreme Court a few years ago
when the Supreme Court redefined the
definition of marriage
this work dignity was used and at the
conclusion of who won that they said
that the constitution gives people the
right
or it has the ability to create
dignity
Clarence Thomas argued against that in a
dissent and he said no
government cannot bestow dignity and
they can't take it away
he said dignity
grows from a seed when a person
understands what the founder said
that all men are created
they are created in the image of God
the sad thing is
Clarence Thomas lost
I don't want to lose
this bill is incredibly important I
don't want to lose the second problem
with the state have a compelling
interest in dignity is it has scared
parents across this state to death
because they look down the road and they
say if the state can say we have a
compelling interest and it's in code
that we are interested in the Dignity of
children
then down the road when a parent says
you're not going to go to public school
where you're going to be homeschooled
and a 15 year old boy says no I'm not
I'm going to where I want to go
then a phone call is made and somebody
knocks on the door and says we're from
children's services and we're authorized
by the state
to be interested in whether you are
providing dignity
to your child or not
they see that as a very big danger
the second thing that this amendment
changes is it plugs in a sentence and it
says that all children in the state of
Tennessee
have a common law right
of protection to be protected against
injury
by a third party or a doctor or anybody
else
it is a common law right
now
you understand that common law was in
place long before The Constitution was
ever written
and all you boys that went to law school
you were you were trained that common
law is what a judge says it is
but of course if that's the case and
there was no tangible truth
to common law then you wouldn't need a
ninth amendment that says the people
retain
common law
so there's a sentence in here that says
that children in Tennessee are protected
by a common law right to not be injured
by a doctor by cutting off viable
healthy body parts or interrupt in the
normal biologic
uh functions that go on in growth
they have a common law right against
that why is that important
well because in Dobbs that overturned
drove
common law was referenced 44 times
so I'm going to say to you if
the courts are listening to common law
arguments
we need to make them
so that's all this amendment does
it strips out a sentence and a half that
gets away from the dignity issue
representative you only get five minutes
so my question to you for brevity as we
use today
what would you like to do with this
amendment because we didn't get there
representative Halsey thank you sir
since it's so important and so brilliant
I'm asking that you or I moved to adopt
a minute thank you chairman Hosley moves
adoption of amendment number three
do we have any discussion representative
Garrett you're recognized
Mr speaker thank you very much and
I want to rise today
let the members know let all tennesseans
know that are listening to my voice that
I support this last legislation
wholeheartedly I also support
and admire my colleague the chairman who
asked for this amendment to be added to
the bill I must though asked to move
that this amendment be laid on the table
for two reasons
the first is while it does
change a couple of words
in this legislation those words are
profound
so I believe in our committee system I
do believe that this should have started
in the committee system to debate why
those words have such profound
distinctions in how it changes this
legislation to potentially make it
suspect for constitutional Challenge and
here's why so my second reason is this
the sentence and I'm going to read it
the state has a legitimate substantial
compelling interest in securing a
Minor's fundamental right
and I want you to listen to this
at common law to be protected from
physical harm to their body including
Anonymous to interference or with
disruption the proper functioning of
their healthy organs according to their
biological
purpose
but for those two words
common law I would have absolutely no
problem
with this amendment and here's why
ladies and gentlemen there is no common
law
right common law as our chairman said is
when we pass legislation here
that particular statute is interpreted
by our judges at the trial level
if the litigants at that particular time
wish to appeal because they disagree
with that interpretation from the judge
they can appeal to our court of appeals
our court of appeals can then surmise on
that particular statute and that's how
judges called case law creates what's
our common law then what do we do with
that when we have a problem and we have
an issue that our judges say is common
law we're down here we're supposed to
create that common law which then
becomes statutory law which but then
becomes more powerful it is what we do
every time we run into something that is
suggested to be the common law Mr
Speaker
we pass a law to make it statutory to
enhance to increase to make these
children more safe because we're passing
a law that does just that it's not
subject to interpretation from a judge
of what the common law means and then
trickle down through our court system
and we don't know because often we have
to interpret ourselves what our court of
appeals and what our Supreme Court
Justice say for the common law it's the
duty that we have to turn that common
law
to statutory law or we place it in our
Constitution and why do we do that
because that's the ultimate protection
that we've sworn an oath to do down here
as we defend make better
our Tennessee Constitution the U.S
Constitution
so there's that order
the common law does not
exists so but for those two words this
debate should take place in committee
and that's why I rise today
with all due respect to the sponsor of
the amendment that this should be laid
on the table Mr Speaker and I so move
second proper promotion properly
seconded departmental situation is
representative Hosley has moved adoption
of amendment number three representative
Garrett has moved that motion to the
table that cuts off all debate for that
of the sponsor representative Hosley
you're recognized
thank you Mr Speaker I'll just be brief
44 times
in dogs
common law was referenced
and because of common law common law
said
that a mother cannot kill
her unborn child
44 times common law is referenced in
Dobbs and because of that
we got to ruling in the overturn of role
so so I disagree with that
second thing is I had no other recourse
but to add this amendment the way I did
and I and I know that going on the house
floor is not a choice thing but it came
through none of my committees so I did
not have that opportunity
and this amendment in no way harms this
bill in fact it does not address the
bill
IT addresses the findings so
I stand behind that thank you the
primary situation representative Hosley
has moved to jobs amendment number three
representative Garrett has moved that
motion to the table we are voting on the
table emotion all those in favor of
Rhode Island Bell Rings those opposed
vote no as every member voted doesn't
remember which change their vote
Mr clerk please take the vote
highs 51 41 days one president I voted
the amendment is table
let the journal
next Amendment Mr Clerk
house amendment number four by
representative Clemens Mr Speaker it was
timely file represent Clemens you're
recognized
thank you Mr Speaker and and thank you
um
sponsor what this amendment does it
simply removes the prohibitions on the
hormone treatment and puberty blockers
but it remains allows the law to
expressly prohibit the surgical medical
procedures it leaves most of the
language intact
um it simply seeks to prohibit the
surgical physical medical procedures
that are irreversible prior to the age
of 18.
under this amendment hormone and puberty
blocker treatment would be allowed those
are reversible
and so from the testimony I heard as
interesting as it was throughout the
committee process
the big concern with most people was the
irreversible versus reversible nature of
the treatment the standard of care in
the state of Tennessee is extensive
and before these children even receive
any hormonal treatment or puberty
blockers they go through a laundry list
of psychological parental consent before
they even get to this treatment so
we also have an issue with the bill as
currently drafted in with the arbitrary
deadline of March of 2024 you're going
to have individuals who are currently
receiving hormone treatment in the state
of Tennessee
who will then have to end that treatment
prior to the age of 18 which creates
several medical issues forcing those
parents to incur additional costs and go
out of state you have removed the
out-of-state nature of the bill or
prohibitions so you clearly don't have
an issue with that
um
so but this amendment let's be clear
this amendment expressly prohibits
surgical medical irreversible procedures
before the age of 18. and I also removed
some of the recitals which don't go in
the code anyway so they're relevant
thank you Mr Speaker I'm good for
adoption of the amendment represent
ation amendment number four
thank you Mr Speaker
members as the maker of this amendment
noted he sits on committees that this
bill went through it went through Health
it went through calendar rules on which
he has a seat the opportunity to make
amendments in our committee process was
there to be debated in the committee
system
the recent discussion that we just had
indicates that indeed had he not had the
opportunity perhaps we should entertain
it but here he is circumventing the
committee system
for that reason I moved the gentleman
from Davidson County's Amendment to the
table
thank you Mr Speaker
that's brown promotion probably second
seconded parliamentary situation is
representative Clemons has moved
adoption amendment number four
representative Reagan has moved that
motion to the table that cuts off all
debate except for that sponsor
representing Clemons you're recognized
thank you Mr Speaker given that our
rules do not prohibit amendments on the
house floor and they expressly provide
for the ability to file amendments on
the house floor this bill is timely
filed and can complete compliance and
gives my colleagues a final opportunity
to do the right thing in this instance I
will be very shocked if anyone votes to
table this motion killing an amendment
that will prevent surgical medical
procedures on minors in the state of
Tennessee that are irreversible for the
purposes of the legislation so I ask
that you vote against the table in
motion thank you Mr Speaker thank you to
the Parliamentary situations
representative Clemens has moved
adoption member number four
representative Reagan has moved that
motion to the table we're voted on the
table in motion all those in favor vote
I when the bell rings all those opposed
vote no
as they remember voted as a member was
changed their vote
Garrett I keasley and I bairdi kapliai
fruits eye
Mr clerk please take the vote
hi 72 19a's
the eyes have it the motion
to table amendment number four is table
next event Miss Clerk
house amendment five by representative
Mitchell and Mr Speaker was timely
followed representative Mitchell you're
recognized
yeah thank you Mr Speaker
my amendment is simple you know in the
committee I heard we didn't need any
unnecessary
surgery procedures on minors
I heard it over and over and over again
and so this kept being misconstrued I'm
going to give definitions so I heard her
little rumor someone was going to try to
misconstrue this so reconstructive
surgery would be surgery that is for
like a child that has cleft palate or
for reconstructive breast surgery after
someone has cancer or reconstructive
surgery as someone gets burned plastic
surgery would come along the lines of
breast augmentation breast lift
liposuction
rhinoplasty or abdomoplasty a tummy tuck
so
either we're going to be consistent or
not so if we're out to protect children
from unnecessary medical surgical
procedures under the age of 18.
this is the amendment to do that but
also in the committee also heard we need
these children need to be comfortable in
their body
and the word you got to hear what I said
these children so I don't know what
these children were referring to which
group instead of all children we were
talking about these children need to be
comfortable in their body so I'm just
bringing this amendment to you know
clarify these means all and unless we're
specifying a group and we're picking out
a group which would be unconstitutional
I know we wouldn't be doing that so I'm
bringing this so we all surgical
procedures cosmetic surgeries are banned
thank you
Mitchell news adoption member number
five probably seconded any discussion on
the amendment chairman Faison you
recognize thank you Mr Speaker
members Mr Speaker
this amendment has absolutely zero to do
with the intent of this bill there's
nothing in this bill that has anything
to do with that
and um
with that I move amendment number five
to the table
that's prop promotion property seconded
environmentary situations representative
Mitchell has moved to adoption amendment
number five representative Faison has
moved that motion to the table that cuts
off all the debate except for that the
sponsor representative Mitchell you're
recognized uh thank you Mr Speaker
perfect he said it for me again he said
this has nothing to do with protecting
children we're PR we're going after
these children he said it you heard him
say it it has nothing to do with
protecting children from unnecessary
medical procedures you know they can get
there uh you know breast enhancements
they can get their nose jobs they can
get their tummy tucks that's okay but
these children can't have any medical
procedures these children you know
the one the one intent of this amendment
is not for you to pass it I know you're
not going to pass it this is for putting
it on the record for when this goes to
court these children will be have to be
addressed and that's going to be the
winning argument thank you
very many situations representative
Mitchell has moved option amendment
number five representation has moved
that motion to the table we are voting
on the table of motion all those in
favor vote I when the bell rings those
opposed vote no
as I remember voted as the members
change your vote Powers I Russell I
dagada
Mr clerk please take the vote
hi 73 19 days I was having the motion to
adopt amendment number five is table
Mr clerk Mr Speaker that brings the
house back to the heel of the Amendments
house health committee amendment number
one
chairman Terry you recognized thank you
Mr Speaker move to withdrawal without
objection withdrawn next minute Mr Clark
house Civil Justice committee amendment
number one filed as house Amendment two
same as Senate amendment number three
Sharon farmer you're recognized uh thank
you Mr Speaker move to withdrawal
without objection withdrawn next minute
Miss Clark Mr Speaker no further
amendments leader Lambert you're
recognized thank you Mr Speaker members
we've we've heard a lot of back and
forth on these amendments today I want
to get us back to what this bill does
it is a very simple bill at its core it
bans dangerous cross-sex hormone
treatments puberty blockers and
disabling medical procedures on minors
all minors I know some have tried to
paint this otherwise and they can argue
that all day long that it affects every
single child the same that could be
subjected to these dangerous procedures
children under the age of 18 for the
purpose of altering their gender
identity these treatments and procedures
have a lifetime of negative consequences
that are irreversible
irreversible when you start cutting off
body parts of a child because you're
telling them that somehow or another
there's something wrong with their body
and they already think that it is
dangerous it is destructive and I will
say it it is evil what those children
need is love and support mental health
treatment and time because in most
circumstances these teenage children
whose bodies are changing so rapidly
they need time to determine how they
feel about that change everybody on this
floor is a recovering teenager those
years are tough your body's changing you
may or may not have felt comfortable
about that when you were going through
it but when a child has gender dysphoria
or body dysphoria when they are
uncomfortable with their appearance the
worst thing that you can possibly do is
say well if we just start cutting off
body parts or giving you medication that
was never designed for this that will
alter your body forever that's the worst
thing you can do and that's not just me
saying that that's every legitimate
scientific study on this because
scientific evidence has not shown that
cross-sex Medical Treatments are
beneficial to children or adolescents in
fact there is evidence of harmful impact
consequently a growing number of
authoritative scientific agencies do not
recommend such treatments instead they
recommend counseling and watchful
waiting for gender confused youth these
children do not need these medical
procedures as children to be able to
flourish as adults again they need
mental health treatment they need love
and support and many of them need time
to be able to grow up to become the
individuals that they were intended to
be with that Mr Speaker I renew my
motion
legal Amber through news is motion any
discussion on the bill representative
Johnson of Knox
thank you Mr Speaker I think we've
already discussed that the Intensive
time spent with Physicians and families
and these young children and that
what we're talking about a lot of times
the hormone blockers and those things
are not
um are not permanent but and the
surgeries that you're referring to are
not happening in Tennessee
and the reality is
we are starting to legislate medicine
and out of 99 folks two people in here
are Physicians and that not necessarily
in in this area and so the reality is we
need to allow doctors and families to
make those decisions and we need to be
honest about the treatments that are
actually happening in our state
we have taken away a woman's right to
determine her health care and her health
outcomes now we've gone into children
but we've also gone into adults with a
bill that's coming up with not allowing
adults that care so the reality is here
we're targeting a group again just as we
were on the last bill and we are
determining that a certain group of
folks can't have hair when a physician
has an oath
to take care of their patients and
that's what they do and we know that the
major health organizations
agree with these treatments and
understand that they are life-saving in
many situations I just want a caution
that this body should not be telling
Physicians what to do typically I hear a
lot of discussion about you know
families being able to make
determinations for themselves
if a doctor and a family feels that
taking hormone blockers is going to be
healthy and productive and life-saving
for these children then that's a
decision that should be made we do not
need to get in the business of
legislating Health Care
foreign
thank you for your comments thank you
out of order
representative Harris
thank you Mr Speaker and
the provincial Health Services Authority
reports that Health Care Providers
refusing to provide puberty blockers to
youth who have started the process can
cause a great level of distress leading
to anxiety and depression and can result
in an increased increased risk of mental
health issues for youth who are already
in the middle of this process what um
what kind of care will they continue to
get
leader Lambert
thank you Mr Speaker and unfortunately
there are children that are being
subjected to these
um these substances now and so that's
why the bill
um after its effective date July 1st any
of the procedures that have been done
before then doctors and their patients
have until next march to actually
stair-step those children off of these
dangerous medications
um it would not be a good idea according
to everything we heard in committee to
immediately just have a halt on that and
so but over time they're able to wean
them off of these so that their bodies
can heal
representative Harris
was a year long enough
to do all of that
literally
so depending upon how long these
children are on these medications that
were not designed for this it may have
caused a significant amount of damage to
them already many of them will suffer
that for a lifetime but stair stepping
them off of those drugs will hopefully
start the healing process and allow
their bodies to avoid such things as
permanent sterilization total loss of
certain body parts bone loss depression
and other harms that currently are side
effects of those medication so giving
them time to stair step off of these
will hopefully avoid those dangers
representative Harris in reading this
language it
um specifically excludes intersex people
cosmetic surgeries and other practices
what made you specifically focus on
those who are transitioning or
transgender youth
leader Lambert
there has long been certain medical
procedures that are definitely medically
and physically necessary for folks that
have diagnosed medical conditions that
are physical in their manifestation what
we're dealing with here are issues of
the heart issues of the Mind mental
health diagnosis of gender dysphoria and
body dysphoria that hits little boys and
little girls alike and again the the
scientific studies on that shows that
mental health treatment
love and support for those children and
yes just time many times allows those
children to live a full life and when
they become adults they can pick their
path on whatever they would like to do
as adults but as children they're in
such a difficult and dynamic time that
we're just saying look we're going to
protect these children from
life-altering procedures but there are
definitely medical conditions that are
Exempted from this bill because those
are again medical conditions that are
been recognized for decades where these
medications actually are very helpful to
intervene in those circumstances
representative Harris so typically a
pubic uh puberty blockers are too Paul
they put a pause on any part of the
transition process to allow
uh and most times a young person to have
the opportunity to make that decision
when they do get to of age of 18.
um
I I have to say as
the only
if this is becoming an odd odd piece of
legislation this one the one before some
of the ones that we're going to see
coming up and as the only
openly lgbtq person in the Tennessee
legislature
uh this is becoming something that's I
don't even talk about lgbtq issues as
much as
some of you all do in this space and
it's becoming not only weird but suspect
and we have order we have three other
not openly
lgbtq Republican colleagues of mine who
can't really open up their mouth and
speak freely about their situation
because they're hiding as well and so I
say that because there's young people
who are uncomfortable with who they are
and can't speak on behalf of themselves
because of people like us in this
legislature
and so while my question is how are we
going to address the mental health of
the young people who are we are going to
be affecting with this legislation how
are we going to make sure that suicide
is not an option for these young people
who are going to be affected by this
legislation
sponsor Larry Lambert
unfortunately that's just not
scientifically accurate there there is
not a pause button that you can put on
puberty there are medications that can
greatly affect the development of a
child's body
um and it many times can last a lifetime
so there's no way to just pause nature
so unfortunately that's just not
accurate as to the other thank you for
your comments
all right
representing Clemens you were on that
list
thank you Mr Speaker
um
you know Mr leader uh thank you for this
uh
legislation your attempts to explain
provide explanation you know we often
look for common ground on issues
difficult like this that directly affect
Tennessee families and children and
based on what I've heard and what I've
read and throughout this entire process
it appears and based on the amendment
vote my mean my Amendment previously
Amendment four it appears that we have
found some common ground on prohibiting
surgical procedures on minors for the
purpose
intended in your legislation
now
I am seriously concerned that the only
area where we cannot find compromise is
the insistence on prohibiting the
hormone treatments and puberty blockers
and the reason for that is is because
those are reversible
so your statements earlier about not
wanting our youth who in your words are
going through uh you know teenage years
and a difficult time and and your words
may be confused
which I don't necessarily agree with
you're it seemed to me the theme of your
concerns were the irreversible nature of
these treatments but
the only area of disagreement we have
here is the hormone of beauty blockers
which are reversible
and so I would ask the sponsor to meet
us in the middle on this issue let's
prohibit these irreversible surgical
medical procedures
on children under 18.
but when they lose the opportunity to
get that hormone or puberty blocker
treatment
that in a way
is irreversible because it's going to be
too late for them if when they become an
adult
they make that decision for themselves
and if we're going to protect individual
liberty and privacy for families and
facilitate Health Care
I I would ask the sponsor please meet us
in the middle and uh and remove that
hormone and puberty blocker treatment
and let's just prohibit that surgical
medical procedure and I would ask the
leader to prove please respond and and
let me know why that's not possible
thank you and sir thank you for what I
hope will be your support of part of
this bill and and I know it is it's easy
to look at the outward effects of a
double mastectomy on a young lady and
how devastating that is and we heard
testimony from young ladies that had
gone through that I that that's
devastating to see their testimony and
hear their testimony on what that was
like that was happening right here in
Tennessee not in large numbers but it
absolutely was and I've spoken to some
of the medical providers that were
conducting that type of surgery so I I
do hope that is something we would all
agree on
the U.S Food and Drug Administration
under this Administration which is
probably not much of a reach to say that
you might support this particular
Administration said this they added a
warning label to for puberty blocking
hormones to monitor patients for a
number of side effects that are very
debilitating and then it says this these
hormones puberty blockers have FDA
approval only for the treatment of
precrosis puberty not gendered dysphoria
and pediatric patients they are not
approved for halting normally time
puberty
additionally many scientific agencies
both in the U.S and internationally do
not recommend medical transition for
youth because the research claiming to
show positive effects for cross-sex
hormones or surgery is
methodologically flawed and not
scientifically reliable the limitations
of these studies include lack of control
groups small sample sizes recruitment
bias non-generalizable study populations
short follow-up times and high numbers
lost to follow-up however studies
finding negative outcomes for medical
transition tend to be of adequate
scientific quality in other words
reliable Studies have shown harmful
effects
watchful waiting is the option
recommended by many scientific agencies
it means deferring transition during
transgender interventions for gender
confused children or youth for an
extended time during which counseling
can occur and a natural desistance or
persistence process can play out all
we're talking about here is waiting to
your 18 to make a life-altering decision
these medications are not designed for
this
they're just not and so whether it's a
surgery or it's a chemical castration it
is still a lifelong harm to these
children
just like a double mastectomy is
represent Clemens thank you Mr Speaker
my time's going to run out the science
has contested on this and I would
thank you
representative grills
thank you Mr Speaker over the past month
or so I've heard several accusations
being or several things been said about
those who oppose this bill or somehow
showing courage I just want to publicly
thank you leader for the courage you
have showed to be the tip of the spear
run this thing through be unwavering and
be a leader for our caucus thank you sir
representative Warner is next
thank you Mr Speaker call previous
question previously been called
objection
don't say enough we're voting all those
in favor of Senate bill one when the
vote I when the bell rings all those
opposed vote no
as every member voted does any member
always change their vote
Mr Clerk
please take the vote
hi 77 16a symbol one and received
contribution majority out here by
declare Pastor objection the motion Rec
series table top next bill Mr clerk
House Bill 66 by leader Lamberth
represent Butler and others relative to
Home Health Services Mr Speaker the
Senate bills on the desk representative
Butler you're recognized
yes sir
thank you Mr Speaker I move to
substitute and conform to Senate bill
0248.
represent Butler Moses subsidian former
Senate Bill 248 with objection so
ordered Butler
I moved passage of Senate bill 0248 on
third and final consideration
representative Butler missed past the
symbol 248 on third and final series
five second Miss clerk Club first
movement Mr Speaker No Limits following
represent Butler are you recognized
thank you Mr Speaker uh this bill is
very simple
and really is an example of what we
really should be doing up here in
simplifying government we are moving the
responsibilities from one Department to
another department to avoid duplication
of services and so it's really that
simple
I renew my motion represent Butler
renews his motion any discussion on the
bill
all right representative Vaughn you're
recognized
thank you Mr Speaker
I rise today to inquire from our
one of our newest members you seem to
like the word simple
do you believe that we are a simple
people representative
yes I do believe we are a simple people
representative Vaughn
I really
that
pardon me point of point of a break Mr
Speaker
being a simple per so do you include
yourself in in the simple World
represent Butler yes represent Vaughn
thank you sir does that mean that you
are a simple man
Butler
um
yes according to Leonard Skinner that
would be that simple man
representative on thank you sir as that
was I'm glad you took the bait on where
I was going sir do you can you give us
any of the lyrics to Leonard Skinner's
Simple Man
I cannot
representative
representative Butler I've just got to
say uh
given the conversation that we've heard
today on the house floor I've been kind
of knocked off my game a little bit if
I'm having to reconnect
re-calibrate some thoughts about
the simpleness of our group here there's
been allegations made about all kinds of
things here today so
um I'll take the title Simple Man and I
will welcome you Mr Simple Man among us
and so we you caught us on a day that
frankly I was Ill prepared for you Mr
Butler but we will see you again
but thank you representative Butler
chairman phaser
thank you Mr Speaker
since this is such a simple bill can we
simply roll it to the hill Mr Speaker
simply that would not be too far
any further discussion
a question been called nem Jackson seen
on all those in favor of Senate Bill 248
vote Iowa when the bell rings I suppose
vote no as every member voted same
memories change your vote
um
Mr Clark please take the vote
eyes 85 no name Samuel 24800 receive
Constitution majority everybody Claire
Pastor I'm Jackson most Rec Center
stable
[Applause]
Bob next bill Mitch Clark
House Bill 81 but leader Lambert
represent Kaplan others relative to
motor vehicle accident reports Mr
Speaker the Senate bills on the desk
representatively you're recognized
golly thank you Mr Speaker I moved to
substitute and conform to Senate bill
0262.
representatively moves the substitute
informed Senate Bill 262 without
objection so order represent Capital you
recognize thank you Mr Speaker I moved
passes through Senate bill 0262 on third
and final consideration representatively
moves past sin Bill 262 on 3565 second
Miss clerk Club First Amendment Mr
Speaker no amendments representative
you're recognized thank you Mr Speaker I
renew my motion representative caploe
renews his motion any discussion on the
bill
representative wrong you back on your
game yet
thank you Mr Speaker I'll try to make
this one a little bit better I've caught
a little bit off guard uh representative
Kaplan you have an interest we like to
know about our new members here you have
an interesting moniker that's attached
to you uh is Kip a family name
representative
but Mr Speaker my real name my full name
is Kipper Isaiah Allen kapli
can you say that one more time
representatively
Kipper Isaiah Allen kapli it would not
be a family name Mr representative on
who so if thank you Mr Speaker if if we
you're telling me that if we pass this
bill
we're going to pass one for the Kipper
there we go representative caplet you're
recognized
I believe this would be for the Kipper
yes sir
well you know it I looked at it and I
was I saw your name and I thought wow
this is
thinking about you going through high
school maybe somebody
you ever been called the hippopotamus
politically
normally if I hear the name Kippur it's
usually from my mama and I'm in trouble
oh representative
you know I look back through the anals
of history and whenever I think of
famous people named KIPP
the only one I can think of is Kip Kano
are you were you named after Kip Kana
representing capfly
I have absolutely no idea who that is
represented by
Kip Kano was a gold medal marathoner he
was uh R.I.P shout out to Kip he was
quite the runner from uh I believe it
was from Ethiopia but he was quite quite
the Sportsman what does your bill even
do uh Mr Kipper
representative Kipper represent Kaplan
thank you Mr Speaker this legislation
will allow state parks to disclose
information contained in motor vehicle
accident reports otherwise made
confidential by Tennessee code annotated
Section 11-1 102 c3a the inability to
disclose information in certain
circumstances would cause unnecessary
issues for both staff and guests so this
would make the disclosure of information
as far as insurance purposes goes easier
for guests within state parks
representative Vaughn
so when
is this one of the things you ran your
campaign on as you were out in your
District saying
you vote for The Kipper
and I'll make sure those accident
reports are right there at your
fingertips
wow that's a
I can see why you're here
that I look forward to seeing the rest
of your legislative packet it's just
absolutely enthralling
we're being Catholic
thank you Mr Speaker we do have the
David Crockett State Park in my district
we are very proud of it uh but this
would not be one of my
focuses on the campaign Trail
representative
thank you sir well obviously the folks
in your District need to be able to they
need to practice with the driving
through the good old Davy Crockett State
Park there because we all will be able
to read their accident reports now so
that's a we love transparency here in
government so thank you for this effort
thank you for being a good sport too
we're glad you're here
foreign
thank you Mr Speaker and I certainly
appreciate the effort given to that by
chairman Vaughn but I would ask y'all to
please explain to Chairman Vaughn the
difference between the anals of history
and the annals of History
[Laughter]
well your name was called
chairman Vaughn
given some of the subject matter that my
friend has in words that my friend has
used in committee testimony and
questioning uh I cannot believe well
actually I shouldn't be surprised that
that was what he noticed but anyway we
uh I'll get i'll study up in my
dictionary and we'll just we'll learn
from there and I ask for your
forgiveness because after all I am
indeed a simple man
foreign
[Music]
objection to the question saying none
all those in favor of Senate Bill 252
vote Iowa when the bell rings those
opposed vote no as every member voted as
they may always change their vote
Miss clerk please take the vote
uh he's 88 no news 10 Bill 262 I'm
received Constitution's majority
everybody Claire Pastor objection the
motion Rick series table
Tom next bill Mr Clark Mr Speaker that
completes the regular calendar next door
Mr Clark unfinished business unfinished
business representative Parkinson you
recognize
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker I move
that the rules be suspended for
immediate introduction and consideration
of house joint resolution 301. Mr clerk
please read the caption abstract
resolution 301 by represent parks and I
know there's a resolution to recognize
and honor the Montford Point Marines
you have heard the caption are there any
objections with objection the rules are
suspended representative Parkinson
thank you Mr Speaker I move adoption of
hjr 301 and asked that all members
voting in the affirmative be listed as
co-prime sponsors with the Tennessee
Black Caucus be listed first
with objection exclusions do we know
that represent Parkinson moves adoption
of house touring resolution 301 probably
seconded any objection to the question
see none all those favorite house joint
resolution 301 say aye Ayo those folks
say no the eyes have it is adopted with
objects the most research table
leader Lambert you're recognized
foreign
speaker just in a procedural motion I
move that house bill is 521 1 313 690
and 883 be heard in the health committee
next week they were in the health
committee this week and they ran out of
time you've heard the motion any
objections without objection so ordered
next door Miss clerk announcements
announcements any announcement chairman
Faison
thank you Mr Speaker members it is time
this Tuesday night that many of you love
what happens in the War Memorial
Auditorium we do have the capital Jam
and it's for your listening pleasure you
might get to hear people like Jojo
Motown singing all the way to Karen
camper I might play something it's going
to be a lot of fun the food's amazing
TPAC is sponsoring it regardless if
you're a Democrat or Republican we love
our Performing Arts Center and believe
in the Arts I hope to see all y'all
there Tuesday night thank you Mr speaker
thank you chair lady carringer
thank you Mr Speaker the population
Health subcommittee was set a final
calendar to be heard March 14 2023 the
deadline to place a bill on notice to be
considered in the subcommittee this year
will be Wednesday March 8th at 3 30 p.m
thank you thank you chair lady Moody
you're recognized
thank you Mr Speaker I have two
announcements may I present them
concurrently please yes ma'am all right
first of all members I would like to
remind you uh from my Tipton County FFA
students they will be in the library the
legislative Library immediately after
session so please just take a moment to
go by and say hi and meet them again and
see the good work that they do now my
second announcement is for our full
education instruction committee which
meets at nine o'clock and so this
Tuesday February 28th we will have a
presentation from Pearson now Pearson is
the company that does our TCAP so if you
have any questions want to come by or
watch us please join us thank you
thank you chairman Howe
thank you Mr Speaker members March 2nd
is upon us next Thursday March 2nd is
the deadline to file your amendments for
the transportation Omnibus bills thank
you thank you chairman speaking thank
you Mr Speaker members the last calendar
for Education instruction sub will be
March 7th last calendar for Education
instruction sub will be March 7th thank
you representative Reedy
thank you Mr Speaker members it's time
for a veterans Caucus meeting on Monday
house hearing Route 3 at 3 P.M once
again veterans Caucus meeting however
all members if you have bills concerning
Armed Forces veterans and their families
and would like to bring them to us for
discussion
be there thank you
thank you representative Reagan chairman
Reagan
thank you Mr Speaker members this
upcoming Monday February 27th The Joint
operations subcommittee on Education
Health and general welfare we'll be
hearing a sense having a sunset hearing
on the Board of Trustees for the
Tennessee State University at 9 00 A.M
again
9 A.M The Joint government operations
committee rule review
will hold our monthly meeting at 11 A.M
afterwards at 1 30 PM the Full House
Government operations committee will
meet to hear our regular calendar all of
these meetings will be in house hearing
room one
thank you Mr speaker thank you chairman
Williams
thank you Mr Speaker members on Monday
afternoon prior to session the the State
Board of Habitat for Humanity will be
hosting their legislative reception in
the legislative Library hope each of you
will be able to attend thank you thank
you Charlie Littleton
thank you Mr Speaker the children and
family Affairs subcommittee is having a
special adoption calendar on March the
7th the deadline to place Bill's own
notice to be considered for the special
calendar is March 1st at 3 30 pm thank
you thank you any further announcements
all right I point representative
speaking to education Administration
committee
next door Miss clerk Robo roll call